welcome back everybody if you're
planning an event a wedding a corporate
event the sterling club the sponsors of
this next segment has you covered here's
how
hi welcome to the sterling club my name
is alexandra batteria i am the director
of event sales at the club
the sterling club is a private upscale
city club in the heart of las vegas so a
few things that are unique about hosting
an event at the sterling club would be
one hour location we're located right by
the convention center so it's really
easy to host a corporate event here you
could have your team you could do hosted
uh
events for your clients we're uh the
perfect location for weddings we have a
lot to offer as far as event spaces you
could do everything from the rehearsal
dinner to the ceremony the reception the
post wedding brunch everything in
between we also have places that you
could do your hair and makeup nails
couples massages so those are great for
weddings when you're getting prepped we
do trials as well so if you want to see
how it looks before your big day we
offer those services as well our members
and guests really enjoy our resort pool
it's a great space to host events
gatherings any type of celebration or
even if you just want to enjoy the day
and sit by the pool
some of the other areas that would be
great for hosting events would be our
stolen ballroom right now we're actually
in our blue room so we host events in
this space as well we've got our veranda
that has a patio that overlooks the pool
so we've got lots of different types of
event spaces each one looks different so
there's a departure from one room to the
next which is pretty exciting if you're
holding an event in more than one space
your guests get to have a different
experience in each of the areas members
love to enjoy some of the different
areas in the club such as our cigar
lounge our main bar and dining room
we do different types of member events
in each of the rooms so we host live
entertainment we do fun mystery dinners
we do wine dinners for the members which
is a multi-course paired wine dinner
which is really fun we do all types of
holiday celebrations for the members so
it's always a good time to come out meet
like-minded people you don't have to be
a member to host an event or just enjoy
the space give us a call and we'll set
you up with a tour or a dining
reservation just let us know what you
need
so fabulous thank you to the sterling
club for sponsoring this segment they
are located right on paradise road right
down the street for more information
call
702-732-9700 or just visit
thesterlingclub.com